cal cuantro will be the starting pitcher
and he's pitched very well he's faced
the tigers three times in his career
holding him
to just one run that's over six innings
all in relief
and a line drive center field base hit
bradley zimmer slipped
trying to come in on the ball so that's
something to keep an eye on here in the
early going with the outfielders that
turf
is definitely soaked bouncy bomb is
short might be two
step on the bag low throw dug out nicely
by bobby bradley to complete the double
play
well he made his pitch the one he wanted
to
only uh rosario can make it just a
little short hop that bradley's ready
for
that's what quantrill wanted high fly
ball
center field zimmer
makes the catch and the tigers are
retired in the top of the first
jose arena is going to take the hill for
the tigers tonight in his 15th start
and there's little doubt after losing
four straight that he wants to try to
get back on track
the one two golf to center field
[Applause]
badu tracks it down one away
there's a real good pitch and that's
where jose irania's got to live
gets ahead with a good fastball and then
has the slider
the ability to throw that slider down
and away out of the zone
gets ahmad rosario to chase jose ramirez
switch header banning left handed and he
is some kind of locked in
driven to deep right field back is
mazara into the corner it's gone a home
run
number 18 for jose ramirez
his 21st career homer against the tigers
his 80th career run batted in against
detroit
he loves doing damage against detroit
well you're going to see a two-seam
fastball
92 but it's upstairs and he didn't get
it in they wanted it in
pulled it right down the line and he's
got his rhythm back
that's home run number 18. one-nothing
tribe here's eddie rosario
easy play for jonathan scope but damage
done by jose ramirez
tigers with the four five and six
hitters here in the second here's the
one
that's a line drive to right in a base
hit bounces in front of harold ramirez
second straight inning the tigers have
the lead off man aboard thanks to a
single
jamer candelario switch hitter banning
left-handed
1-2 fly ball left center field that's up
the gap
run maggie off the wall miguel cabrera
all the way to third
and chamber candelario has himself a
double and the tigers got something
cooking offensively here in the second
jamer went right with this pitch he hits
it where
it was pitched and he gets a good result
it's a change up
you can see it's sinking down and away
but look at how jamerr stayed down on it
shot it just
where it was pitched 2-2 swing and a
miss he wanted the strikeout and he got
it yeah it's a beautiful sequence there
for quantum he went up and away with
that slider maybe not where he wanted it
but he got it
this one now he follows it up with
something down and in
and that's his strength as he hit her so
he wanted that slider
3-1 and he walked him the bases are
loaded with tigers
for harold castro eighth pitch of the
at-bat on its way
and he walked him we're all tied thanks
to the bases loaded walk to harold
castro
and the tigers continue the threat here
in the second
fifth batter of the inning for the
tigers it's jake rogers
drives one to right that's in for a base
hit
one run is home that gives the tigers
the lead
after candelario scores the tigers keep
them loaded
jake rogers with his 12th rbi of the
season gives detroit a 2-1 lead
swinging a miss he strikes out badou two
down
there he got a head in the count made a
good pitch
had him reaching he gets the second out
with no more damage
he goes right back up the middle and
hernandez is there
the throw is on the money and cuatro
gets out of any further
trouble tigers get a pair and take a two
to one lead
jose arena facing bobby bradley to start
the second
bobby bradley sends a high fly ball deep
left center field
going to the bleachers home run number
seven for
bobby bradley man he has shown some
really good
opposite field power i think that's his
fourth home run
this year out of his seven that have
gone to left center field
and that one was no cheapie i'll tell
you what
that one was deep cesar hernandez flight
out the center his first time up
he smoked that one though off speed
pitch deep right field and
gone to souvenir city and the indians
take a three to two lead
my point it looks like a change up to me
three solo homers for cleveland
in each of the first three innings here
tonight
that's their 10th home run in the last
four games
they are hitting the long ball they're
back to doing that again
now harold castro bases loaded walk
picked up an rbi in the second
2-0 to harold castro that is hammered to
right center field that'll get all the
way to the wall
zach shorts got good speed he's getting
the windmill around third
he will score we are tied thanks to
harold castro's
rbi double here in the four i don't know
what it is
in cleveland tonight but it seems like
balls are just
jumping off the bats first pitch
swinging in a fly ball deep center field
bradley zimmer going back he looks up
and he's gonna have to play that off the
wall
castro had to hold on for a moment now
he'll be waved home and then crawling
back to first or third base
so second and third jonathan scopo
for two and this is a fly ball to right
harold ramirez comes in on it
carol castro's gonna tag and he is in
there safely to give the tigers the lead
the sacrifice fly from jonathan scope
gets it done it's 4-3 detroit
now the bottom of the fourth already had
three lead changes
and now bobby bradley going the other
way again good it is deep
it is gone to the bleachers
bobby bradley goes boom again his second
home run of the night
and the fourth for the indians and we're
tied again
he said it man it's home run derby and
this is a picture-perfect swing again by
bradley
this was a line shot first and second
two away
harold castro oh
left field and it's to drop for a hit
coming around third with a go ahead run
and scoring is mazara so with two outs
and nobody on base a double a walk in a
little blue
single puts the tigers back in front
five to four
and up comes jose ramirez oh
what the heck just happened that ball
went off
his cheek he was so far out in front of
that ball that it hit off the edge
i don't think you've ever seen that
before never find a tougher dude in
baseball than this guy
runners at the corners for the tigers
and only one away and here comes miguel
cabrera
and the one one is hit high in the air
plenty deep enough
tagging and coming home is jonathan
scope cabrera gives the tigers a two-run
lead
here's the payoff candelario rips one to
right
that'll hop in front of harold ramirez
grossman's gonna try and score
the throw way up the line grossman
scores
jamer candelario delivers an insurance
run for the tigers
make it 7-4 in the six and now jonathan
scope
double an rbi and a run scored scope
with a liner to left and mercado can't
make the catch
castro scores it's an rbi single
and make it akil badu scoring as well
it's a two-run
single for jonathan scope brian garcia
gets
the bottom of the seventh against the
bottom third of the cleveland order
let's see if he can get hernandez here
how wave and a miss and the ball game is
over
tigers win it in convincing fashion 9-4
solid offensive day for detroit to start
this double header
15 hits